let me give you a definition and I'm
gonna give it to you in terms of this
guy over here if this is true which it
is okay I can retell this story rather
than from give me time and I'll tell you
how big it is right
I can retell the story from the other
side right I can say well all right in
you're doubling machine okay
that's where my base goes if you end up
32 times bigger than when you started
how long have you been in the machine
for right now because of what I've got
over here I already know what the answer
is it's just five okay but can you see
excuse me it's the same characters it's
the same piece of information but I've
just rearranged it so now I'm telling
the story in Reverse okay so here I've
got what am I got here I've still got
two growth right here what I've got here
is my final size now is my input right
that's what I'm asking you about that's
what you ended up final size and the it
to the question down is well how long
did you put it in for what's the time
how long was it there okay now on the
basis of this you can think about a
whole bunch of numerical examples that a
correspond to these guys over here okay
so let me give you some example let's
again think about this if I say this
okay and by the way the way I read this
is and there's lots of different ways to
say if I think this is the least
ambiguous litsa clearest is log base 2
of 1 okay that's a helpful way because
up here the base is on the same side
over here and that's the base over here
okay so you've got the same language
meaning the same thing
well our base 2 of 1 okay now this void
equation is asking a new question rather
than asking how big you're gonna end up
this is asking how long were you in
there how long is it you stick your
object in the box port right does that
make sense
so how long you have to stick around
back to the bar
to be your original size Edsel you don't
have to stick it in for any time it's
already that size does that make sense
okay
again let's think about this what if and
you'll notice I'm just taking the
equations we wrote before right if I say
log base 2 of 1/2 right excuse me that
means how long are you growing how long
does it take for your object to be half
of its original size
well that was here backwards in time
right because going forwards in time
you're getting bigger and a half is
smaller right so you've gone backwards
in time does that make sense
I think about this guy I can write
excuse me now I'm just gonna give this
answer to you right if I um if I put my
object in my growing machine my doubling
machine and it ends up 32 times bigger
than what I started right do you agree
do you see but that's the same as
putting it in the W machine until it's
four times bigger and then the time I
add is the time it takes to get eight
times bigger does that make sense
because let's think about it one step at
a time right excuse me
it takes two minutes to get four times
bigger than what is there then it takes
another three minutes to get eight times
bigger than that right so you can see
because the final sizing here is four
times bigger then eight times bigger
that's why you'll be 32 times bigger and
you're adding up times one more let's
think about this all if you can work
this one out
let's do okay
now somebody you might be able to recite
this law for me okay it's called the
power law because it's gonna have to do
me this power up here but I wonder if we
get into what's going on first can we
work it out this is how are you gonna
take a my doubling machine right and I
want to be this big by the end that's
125 times bigger it's pretty much right
that's okay my dumping machine is pretty
quick okay think about with me first
it's going to have to grow five times
bigger than this and then grow
another five-time speak up and then grow
another five times bigger that's five
cubed isn't it okay but that up there is
just the reverse of this right how long
is it gonna take me to grow five times
begun well by definition it's that
that's how long it'll take me to get
five times bigger and then you have to
do it again
right to grow up to 25 and then you do
it one more time
take it up to 125 right first chuckle
time second junket ride third chunk of
time and of course you've just got three
things I'll just collect like terms and
you notice my power of three it's just
kind of hopped up the front and become
this number at the beginning which we
call the coefficient okay so excuse me
this idea of logs being about time to
grow how long do you take to get to this
size as opposed to I know how long tell
me how big I am right that's all there
is to logs that's all there is to them
right so now we're ready now that you
get the metaphor now you're ready to
have a look at the laws and prove them
they're really simple if you have this
in your head okay so for example let's
have a look at this one here okay so you
can see here excuse me if I add two logs
together with the same base the same
base kind of means like I'm thinking
about the same machine right cuz you got
different machines it's a bit confusing
you can't really combine their times
together so if I've got the same machine
that ends up at the same base if you add
these then the four and eight they get
multiplied okay now remember this is an
inverse of this so everything is
backwards this is the reverse on this
law see that if you add logs you
multiply that number if you multiply
exponential you add that number can you
see it's exactly the same bit backwards